[Music]
yeah who's this hidden your phone over
and over you want to keep going to my
phone like you don't trust me this
extended new look at Rob Kardashian and
blac Chyna's a reality show is giving us
a glimpse into their lives and drama
what are you still texting other females
about just wanted to apologize
oh no why he think it is too game the
pair certainly have their ups and downs
and it looks like Rob's reported
depression will be a topic of
conversation what could I do to help
what really triggers you to go into a
dark hole it's a big change to go from
being inside for like four years now
being outside robbing China premiere
September 11 but this Sunday we'll see
Rob talk about the aftermath of his
fight with China with Kim and Khloe on
the midseason finale of Keeping Up with
the Kardashians my plan is not to have a
kid with somebody and not be with the
person that's just bizarre to me
I know Robin Chyna have a long way to go
but I'm really happy that they are
working things out